even though you may know tv and movies
aren't real
it can still break your heart when your
fictional friends fall into a black hole
or get stabbed in the neck by their evil
clone unfortunately for us
and our emotions this makes for great
storytelling so
here are some of the saddest on-screen
death scenes you'll ever see
in the original star wars trilogy han
solo
undergoes a classic heroic
transformation when you first meet him
he's a callous rogue who pushes others
away
and only cares about cash but by the
time return of the jedi rolls around
he's found redemption purpose and the
love of his life
it's a nice tidy ending which is what
made han's actual fate in star wars the
force awakens
so grueling apparently even in a galaxy
so far
far away happy endings are never quite
so easy while fans spent 30 years
imagining that
han and leia lived happily ever after it
turns out that their bouncing little boy
became the next darth vader their
marriage hit the rocks
and han went back to smuggling by the
time the older han
finally makes his appearance his famous
wisecracks are now tinged with a sense
of loss
this is a millennium falcon you're han
solo i used to be
what makes han's death the saddest scene
in star wars history though
is that he dies simply for trying to do
right by his son
even though the younger han would have
hit the road and the older han knows
kylo ren
will probably kill him the famously
scruffy nerf herder can't help but make
one final effort to redeem the kid he
raised
from the moment han first approaches
kylo every fan in the universe knows
he's about to get his obi-wan moment
but that only makes the eventual
lightsaber stab
even harder to watch breaking bad was
packed full of dark grisly and
uncomfortable moments
but the one that everyone still winces
over is the scene where jesse's
girlfriend jane
asleep after a last hurrah drug binge
chokes on her own vomit
and walt does nothing it's an easy
solution to prevent
jane from exposing him which she'd
earlier threatened to do
his conscious decision to allow jane to
die
might be the moment where walt truly
broke bad in the most awful way
from that point on there was no going
[Music]
back
disturbing as this was it's even worse
when jesse's later girlfriend
andrea is shot by todd in the show's
penultimate episode
while jane and jesse were largely
terrible for each other
andrea is just a single mother trying to
give her son brock a better life
and she's only murdered because jessie
refuses to cook meth
for todd's sociopathic gang of neo-nazis
todd casually shoots her in the back of
the head while jesse watches
leaving brock an orphan just so you know
this isn't personal
[Applause]
the scene is brief horrible and
impossible to forget
especially for ian posada the young
actor who played brock who
according to the hollywood reporter
reportedly teared up when he was shown
the scene
the late michael clark duncan was always
a phenomenal actor
but the one movie that everyone will
always remember him by
is the screen adaptation of stephen
king's the green mile
in which he plays john coffey a
wrongfully accused death row inmate with
supernatural abilities
the film is filled with tons of
tear-jerker moments as coffee's kindness
honesty and compassion for others is
shown in sharp
contrast to the horrible treatment he
receives from society
compares though to the intensely
heart-wrenching scene at the end of the
film
where coffee is finally executed in the
electric chair
the characters are crying just as much
as the audience and the little touches
such as coffee asking not to have the
black hood put over his face
since he's afraid of the dark or the
close-up of coffee and tom hanks paul
edgecombe squeezing hands
leave a lasting impression what's
amazing about sam
raimi's 2002 spider-man is that it
somehow made the best
superhero origin story ever even better
in the original comics peter parker is
just an average
selfish teenaged kid preoccupied with
girls in popularity
until his big ego results in his father
figure getting killed
hey michelangelo don't forget we're
painting the kitchen right after school
got it
sure thing uncle ben don't start without
me
basically while the genetically altered
spider bite gives peter strength and
confidence
it's the weight of his own mistakes that
forces him to grow up and take
responsibility
all the key elements are the same
between raymie's film adaptation
and its source material why his words
are spoken
remember with great power comes great
responsibility
peter lets a criminal get away you know
the drill but remy's film made one
slight alteration that cranked up the
tears
here we see uncle ben die right before
peter's eyes
surrounded by onlookers uncle ben
[Music]
over here uncle ben the entire movie
relies on this scene working
and luckily cliff robertson and toby
mcguire knock it out of the park
if there's one big reason the marvel
cinematic universe hasn't shown uncle
ben's death perhaps it's because they
knew they couldn't top this scene
or this one
[Music]
it seems like more game of thrones
characters ended up dead than alive
and that's not even counting the whole
army of corpses marching down westeros
but the loss that hurt the most was
hodor the lovable strong man who
protected bran with his dying breath
even though his tragic situation in life
was well
brand's fault time travel is crazy eh
though hodor spent much of the show's
run as a humorous oaf who just said the
same
gibberish word over and over his death
scene completely redefined the character
forever
revealing that hodor actually meant hold
the door
and that he'd known this whole time that
he'd someday have to sacrifice his life
doing just that
twitter and presumably the actual world
erupted in sadness following hodor's
death
the whole thing only gets more
depressing when you re-watch the first
season and realize that he's been
lending a massive hand to bran this
whole time
the first words ever spoken to hodor are
help brand down the hall
black panther was perhaps the cinematic
event of 2018
and a huge part of that success was due
to the film's antagonist
eric killmonger as played by michael b
jordan whether killmonger is
unforgivably torching wakandan
traditions
sending out mass shipments of weaponry
are simply crying at the loss of his
father
he's always riveting impossible to look
away from and deeply sympathetic
i found my daddy with panther claws in
his chest you ain't the son of a king
you're a son of a murderer
killmonger is more than just a great
character though because as the atlantic
points out his story also symbolizes
the void permanently imposed on african
culture by the transatlantic slave trade
these items aren't for sale how do you
think your ancestors got these
you think they paid a fair price or did
they take it like they took everything
else
these deeper themes are exactly what
makes his death scene so powerful
after being mortally wounded by the
film's hero t'challa
killmonger mentions that his wakandan
father always praise the natural beauty
of his homeland
out of compassion t'challa then brings
his wounded opponent
back up the mountain so they can watch
the sunset together and offers to use
wakanda's advanced medical technology to
heal him
killmonger refuses to be saved instead
he asks to be buried at sea
just burying me in the ocean with my
ancestors that jumped from the ships
because they knew death was better than
bondage
while black panther had a lot of moments
that will go down in pop culture history
this was one of the biggest we just
made out a couple times we just made out
a couple times
oh barb the world hardly knew ye despite
the fact that barb only made it through
a few episodes of stranger things before
being shredded to pieces by the
demogorgon
this minor character spawned a huge
number of fans collectively called the
cult of
barb by salon what it comes down to
really is that shannon purser's
character
is just so intensely relatable while
most people haven't hung out at the pool
while an otherworldly monster storms out
of the woods and drags them into a dark
dimension
many people can empathize with the
feeling of being left out or trying to
do the right thing while their flaky
friend just gets some action in the
other room
barb's death scene is perhaps the
ultimate example of what it feels like
being the
so-called third wheel and that's
probably why so many stranger things
fans still miss her to this day
at the beginning of the 2004 relaunch of
battlestar galactica
anastasia d duolla was one of the show's
beacons of hope youthful optimistic and
full of life
d weathers the many challenges the fleet
experiences eventually finding love with
lee
apollo adama even when d and apollo's
marriage doesn't work out
she continues being one of the show's
brightest characters as the fleet
searches through the universe for their
mythical homeland
earth you have no idea what's happened
to you
today is just another day things quickly
collapse when everyone finds out that
earth is actually a post-apocalyptic
wasteland
as the crew tries to recover from this
horrible reality
dee and apollo go out on a date and
reconnect it's a sweet
simple moment leading audiences to
believe that maybe now
even after the crew has seemingly lost
everything there's still hope for the
future
then dee goes back to her locker smiles
in the mirror
savors the moment she shared with lee
and ends her life
the scene is so shockingly tragic that
actress candace mcclure told sci-fi that
merely reading the script
left her floored it's safe to say that
her fans had similar reactions
if there's one thing that marvel's
avengers infinity war will go down in
history for
other than being the most ambitious
cinematic crossover ever
it's the fact that at least half of
everybody's favorite superheroes get
killed by a bad guy snapping his fingers
some infinity war deaths may be more
permanent than others
like loki and heimdall but every single
one of them hurts like crazy the biggest
shock
though might be that moment on titan
where a certain wall crawling web
spinning underdog turns to dust
while everybody else from star-lord to
black panther
can barely blink before they're wiped
out of existence spider-man knows
something is coming he
feels his spidey sense tingling but
there's nothing he can do to stop his
inevitable erasure
and then came that damn line
i don't feel so good
and finally as audiences everywhere let
out a collective ugly sob
i don't want to go i don't want to go
start please
oh you don't want to go according to
screen rant both of these soul-crushing
lines were improvised by actor tom
holland
sure we all know that peter is coming
back what with far from home taking
place
after avengers end game but still that
didn't make watching him go away
any less heartbreaking sure bambi losing
his mom was a downer but if there was
one
animated classic that made millions of
kids sob into the arms of their confused
mothers
it was don bluth's 1988 dinosaur film
the land before time
what made the land before time such a
fantastic kids movie
and what the numerous sequels got so
wrong was that the script pulled no
punches
from the first scene bluth's movie
paints a vivid portrait of a once
beautiful world brought to the edge of
despair by famine
where a herd of dinosaurs struggle to
find food while defending attacks from
the outside
despair is everywhere but at least you
know littlefoot will be okay
thanks to his wise strong devoted mother
until
suddenly everything goes haywire first a
sharp tooth storms in
then an earthquake wrecks the place and
littlefoot is left stranded
as rain and thunder pour down the sad
little dinosaur wanders alone through
the blighted landscape
desperately crying out for his mom
[Music]
mother where are you
when he finds her she's already half
dead he pleads for her to get up
and when she says
[Music]
even the parents in the audience are
probably wiping their eyes
one of the most memorable scenes of 1994
as the lion king
is also the most heartbreaking the
traumatic death of mufasa
after saving his son from a stampede the
doomed king desperately
claws his way to safety only to get
thrown back into the stampede's path by
his own brother
scar
afterward the orphaned simba tries and
tries to wake up his father
until he finally accepts there will be
no waking up he spends a long moment
nestled against his father's corpse
the iconic death scene has a
shakespearean brutality and it sets the
stage for everything that comes after
simba's legacy is ripped to pieces by
his own uncle
it's grim and brutal and not what you
normally expect from a disney cartoon
if you're part of a generation who grew
up on the never-ending story the playful
grin of falcore the luck dragon probably
still comes back to you from time to
time
what you might forget is that like so
many of your favorite movies from
childhood
the underlying themes tend to be dark
sure there's giant turtles and friendly
giants but in a sense they're just
decoration for a story that's all about
keeping hope alive in the face of utter
despair
perhaps the saddest moment in the entire
film is the death of our tax the noble
horse
the beautiful animal meets his painful
end while accompanying his young owner
atreyu
through the swamp of sadness true to its
name the swamp's oppressive magic
threatens to smother
any who travel through it with their own
anguish and that's exactly what happens
to poor artix
no matter how much atreyu begs and
pleads for his friend to save himself
the horse is too consumed in his own
hopelessness and allows himself to drown
in the muck
it's been nearly a decade and a half
since ang lee's brokeback mountain first
hit theaters and it's easy to forget
what a cultural event it was a love
story between cowboys played by jake
gyllenhaal and heath ledger
brokeback mountain won awards accolades
and a domestic gross of over 80 million
dollars against a 14 million dollar
budget
the story revolves around the
decades-long relationship between jack
twist and anna stillmar
which tragically ends when annas
discovers through a postcard that his
friend and lover has died
when ennis calls for more information he
is told that jack was killed when a tire
he was changing exploded but ns can't
help but consider this might not be the
truth
he imagines a more horrific story with
his mind flashing to the idea of jack
being brutally beaten to death with a
tire iron
jack's death is a total heartbreaker but
the uncertainty just makes it worse
in the real world the chances that
you've cried over a lost volleyball are
quite slim
however you probably also never found
yourself stranded on an island with
nothing but a random piece of sports
equipment to keep you company
which is the situation in which tom
hanks character finds himself in 2000's
cast away
though few people have struggled with
what hank's character endured
it's easy to imagine how years of
extreme isolation could force an
inanimate object to become a friend
that's why when chuck finally escapes
the island it's so heartbreaking when he
accidentally loses wilson
he dives into the water risking his life
and his chance to get home all to save a
volleyball
he eventually gives up but his cries to
his friend are so full of anguish
it feels like he's leaving a real person
to drown
i'm sorry
i'm sorry wilson well
i'm sorry the scene also marks the key
moment where chuck begins a traumatic
transition back to the civilized world
a place where volleyballs aren't allowed
to be your friends even if you draw
lovable faces on them for 16 years
hugh jackman brought marvel's adamantium
clawed mutant renegade to life earning
fan adoration and a guinness world
record for
longest career as a live-action marvel
superhero in the process
sadly all good things must come to an
end while everyone hoped 2017's logan
would be
a dark brilliant conclusion to the most
popular x-men
story few could have predicted just how
painful it would be to see marvel's
toughest
grittiest superhero reduced to a bitter
aching old man
poisoned by his own adamadium with claws
that didn't quite pop right anymore
while wolverine never finds true
happiness or peace
logan does find something of a family in
a battle against his clone
wolverine gives his life to save a group
of innocent mutant children
including a girl who becomes a
daughter-like figure to him
laura as logan dies impaled and covered
in blood
he clutches laura's hand smiles and says
most superhero movies leave the audience
walking out with smiles and laughter
but logan was definitely the one where
everyone left in tears
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one